ما أبلغناه اليوم
في lancet هو مجموعة بيانات جديدة في
المرحلة
الأولى من تجربة لقاحنا والتي تعني
أكثر من ألف شخص
وأه أولاً ، تبدو بيانات السلامة
مطمئنة للغاية في كل هؤلاء الأفراد ،
ولا يوجد أي مخالفة ضارة خطيرة لا شيء
مهم  القلق
وبعد ذلك عندما ننظر إلى الاستجابات المناعية
التي تكون موجودة في كل شخص نرى
أجسامًا مضادة معادلة جيدة ، فهذه هي
تلك التي نبحث عنها
والتي يجب أن تمنع انتقال
الفيروس إلى الخلايا
، بالإضافة إلى ذلك نرى الذراع الأخرى
لجهاز المناعة.  النظام ،
عادةً ما يطلق على الذراع الخلوية اسم الخلايا التائية التي توجد
بأعداد كبيرة أيضًا
حتى بعد جرعة واحدة من اللقاح ،
لذلك
حقًا أه نتائج في النهاية
العليا لتوقعاتنا ، لذلك نحن الآن
نمضي قدمًا ، قمنا بتطعيم
حوالي 10000  الأشخاص في أه التجارب حتى
الآن ونحن نتابع تلك التجارب للتأكد من فعاليتها
لمعرفة ما إذا كان اللقاح
يعمل حقًا ، لذا الآن أنت
تشحن في المرحلة الثالثة
لديك تجارب في  إن المملكة المتحدة البرازيل
وجنوب إفريقيا قيد التنفيذ ،
هل يمكنك أن تقول إلى أي مدى تقترب الآن
من بئر لقاح نهائي ،
يجب أن أضيف أن أكبر تجربة
يجب أن تبدأ قريبًا وهذا
في الواقع في الولايات المتحدة ،
لذلك نأمل أن يكون ذلك قيد التنفيذ في
في الأسبوعين أو الثلاثة أسابيع القادمة
، يعتمد مدى اقترابنا بالطبع على
معدل الإصابة بالعدوى في مجموعة التجارب
منخفضة نسبيًا في المملكة المتحدة ولكنها مرتفعة
في جنوب إفريقيا
ومرتفعة في البرازيل ونتوقع
ذلك في بعض الولايات التي نعمل فيها
في
أه في الولايات المتحدة ، ستكون معدلات الإصابة
مرتفعة أيضًا ،
لذا من الصعب جدًا الاتصال
بشهر سبتمبر ،
وقد يكون شهر أكتوبر ، ولا أحد يعرف حقًا ،
وأننا أعمى عن البيانات كما هي ،
وسأكون معك في  ثانيًا ، لم تكن في حالة
جيدة
، حيث تم نقل مريضة مصابة بفيروس كوفيد -19
من غرفتها
إلى وحدة العناية المركزة
في المركز الطبي لجورجيا في شمال شرق جورجيا في
غينسفيل ، جورجيا ،
وهي ولاية تضاعفت فيها الوفيات المرغوبة تقريبًا
منذ
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر.  إنه أمر مرهق ،
لقد دفعني إلى أقصى حدود لي ، فقد
أظهر لي أنني أقوى بكثير مما كنت
أعتقد أنني
كريستينا هابن هي في هذا
المستشفى الذي يقع في جزء من
جورجيا كانت منطقة ساخنة في وقت مبكر من
كوفيد  أزمة
لكن الأرقام بدأت في إسقاط الدولة ،
بدأت في إعادة فتح
خبراء بارزين يقولون لما يحدث
الآن فقط عندما تعتقد
أننا ربما نتقدم في هذا الشيء ،
فإنه سيعود
ونبدأ من جديد ، وكان
هذا ممرًا لـ
المرضى المنومين بالمستشفى العاديين
تم تحويله الآن إلى
وحدة رعاية مركزة إضافية
لمرضى كوفيد فقط يعالج الدكتور ستيفن مورجان
العديد منهم ، نعم ، يجب أن
أعترف أنني اعتقدت أننا ربما كنا
واضحين كما تعلمون ، أعتقد أن الكثير منا فعل
الدكتور مورجان  يقول إن الأعداد المتزايدة المرغوبة
تجعل الوظيفة أكثر صعوبة ، مما
يزيد من إجهاده ،
فهو يتفقد مريضًا مطمعا في منتصف العمر
ويشعر بالامتنان لتقدمه الذي حققه
رجل قوي حقيقي بدأ في
بعض عصيان الإيقاع في أقرب وقت  عندما أتى
إلى المستشفى ، كان
شعورًا مختلفًا تمامًا حيث دخلت الممرضة المسجلة
هابين إلى هذه الغرفة ،
هذا الرجل يعالج في وحدة مخصصة لهذا
الغرض ،
هذه ليست وحدة العناية المركزة ولكن هناك قلق من
أنه قد ينتهي به الأمر إلى هناك.
كان المريض هنا منذ يومين ،
وهناك الكثير من القلق الواضح
لأي شخص في وحدة كوفا
ولكن بشكل خاص بالنسبة لهذا الرجل
لأنه كبير السن جدًا
، فقد تم إعطاؤه ماء السكر للحفاظ
على نسبة السكر في الدم
وكذلك الأنسولين ، أحد أصعب
الأمور هو
مع العلم أن المرة الأخيرة التي
رأت فيها عائلة ذلك المريض
قد تكون هي المرة الأخيرة التي
يتمكنون فيها من رؤيتهم ، فإن
هذا المركز الطبي جاهز لمزيد
والمزيد من المرضى الذين يتم قبولهم في
هذا الهيكل غير المعتاد الذي يجلس في
ساحة انتظار سيارات بالمستشفى ،
سيبدأ المرضى قريبًا في الحصول عليه  تم نقله
داخل
هذا المستشفى الذي تم تشييده بسرعة
ويتكون من 44
حاوية شحن مجمعة معًا ،
وهناك 20 غرفة
للمرضى المغطاة كل ما تحتاجه
سوف ندخل إلى غرفة مستشفى تقليدية
داخل المستشفى نحن قادرون على
القيام به هنا في هذه الوحدة ،
كل شخص نتحدث معه هنا يعبر عن
فخره بما يفعلونه
ولكن مع ارتفاع الأرقام ، فإن
القلق يخشى جيدًا في بعض الحالات ،
أعتقد أنك  تعرف
على ضغوط ما بعد الصدمة
وهذا ما أشعر به ، أعني أنه
أشعر وكأنني أشعر بشيء يجب أن نكون
قادرين على منع حدوثه ، وكأننا
لا نملك السيطرة عليه في الواقع
ومن ثم يموت المرضى ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو حصلنا عليه  قريب جدًا
منه ، يشبه فقدان أحد أفراد الأسرة ،
هؤلاء الأطباء والممرضات ينظرون أيضًا إلى
أفراد الأسرة
الآخرين الذين يعملون معهم لمحاربة هذا
الفيروس طالما أن جاري توكمان سي إن إن جينزفيل ،
جورجيا